hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the research resource
identifier initiative what is needed for
the scholarship in 21st century
presented by dr. Anita vandross key a
scientific lead at neuroscience
information framework Centre for
research and biological systems at
University of California at San Diego
I'm Suzy Valdez of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar that presented by Lavery's
lab roots is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
invite everyone and remind them that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that
green Q&A button located at the lower
left of your presentation window and
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also note that
you're viewing the presentation and the
slide window to enlarge that window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
hearing or seeing the presentation click
on the support button at the top right
or use that Q&A button and let us know
we're having a problem that presentation
is educational and it offers educational
credits please click on the button in
the lower left window and follow the
process for obtaining your credits
please join me now in welcoming dr.
Anita Vander Oski I will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome dr. ben
ghazi
hi welcome I hope everyone can hear me
okay thank you so much for that
wonderful introduction I really
appreciate it so thank you again so much
for coming everyone and I would love to
talk to you today about key biological
resources and the our ID system and this
is real
one of the things that is really needed
for scholarship in the 21st century I
mean we are we are going to be moving on
we have these web enabled technologies
and the goal is to bring scholarship
into that 21st century so the topics
that will be I'll be covering in this
presentation is what are these our IDs
we'll talk I'll talk a little bit about
the past present and future of these the
RIT for authors so how do I make my
paper better how do I make my grant
better and I'll talk a little bit about
the new guidelines from the National
Institutes of Health our IDs for
publishers so again there are some
reasons why a publisher a journal would
want to join the RIT initiative and I'll
point out some of those those things and
then of course if you write your own
tools if you create a mouse or an
antibody if you create a software tool
how do you track impact and so that is
the kind of last section of what I'll
cover and I will try to show you and
convince you that our IDs are actually a
really good way to to go for tracking
impact and making your research a little
bit better a little more reproducible a
little bit more rigorous and a little
bit more transparent okay so are these
are backed by two major NIH initiatives
NIH projects the first one is the
neuroscience information framework or
also called myth it was funded in 2008
as an NIH blueprint initiative and it
established a lot of the aggregation
platforms that you know we've had we've
been able to use since then to actually
enable this a lot of the 21st century
scholarship that we are really working
and pushing for now it created a lot of
comprehensive data registries including
those for antibodies and also a lot of
digital projects such as databases and
software tools and then there's the
niddk information network
so-called DK net that was funded in 2012
and what it did is it allowed us to
create a very generic platform that
allowed us to also customize any version
of any of the data sets that we had and
display them in a specific way so it
expanded a lot of the data indices it
expanded the reach to become much more
consistent with a broader biological
project as opposed to simply
neuroscience so what we aim to do really
is to actually identify and monitor the
scientific food chain and now when we
look at this the question really becomes
ok why is there a picture of a chicken
up here actually duck alright well
research resources we think of just like
ingredients in a recipe and so here on
the left hand side what you'll see is
that there are some you know incredibly
lovely recipes so you know whoops there
we go
there's a you know duck innards and
there's sugar there's soy sauce both
light and dark and all of these things
and you can see that in this particular
recipe site not just there are a bunch
of images which I would call the results
but also there's a lot of ingredients
and these these things are actually
linked but research resources things
like antibodies organisms cell lines
cell lines that's an important one and
all kinds of other tools are these sorts
of things but they're very seldom linked
and so what we'd like to do is maybe you
know essentially bring our ingredients
of the of the scientific variety into
the 21st century as we say so in the age
of global search we should be able to
easily answer just two extraordinarily
basic questions and we should be able to
do it across all of biomedicine these
two questions are what resources were
used to produce the results of this
particular study which antibody which
selling right what are the other studies
that have used this particular antibody
we should be able to answer that but it
actually turns out that even with Google
Scholar we really can't answer this
question very well or at all now this
kind of question is really important for
rigor and appreduce ability it is very
important for tracking the impact of
these research resources if I made a
mouse I want to know who used it I want
to know how they used it the same thing
for any anyone using a software creating
a software tool we want to give credit
to that resource creator we also want to
aggregate data we want to understand who
else you use that antibody because if
I'm having trouble with that antibody in
my lab then I want to see all of the
papers that use that very specific
antibody so that I can figure out why it
works why it doesn't work
right the monitor the health of the site
of scientific food chain is the last
piece so if there's a problem with the
cell line how do we know that how do we
know when we're reading a paper that
there is actually something that's
reported about that cell line
well after potentially the paper was
published but now we know that this
particular cell line was you know let's
say transformed and became a HeLa cell
and that happened at the manufacturer it
didn't even happen in the lab and we
know that maybe we ought to know that
when we're reading a particular
publication and why can't we do this now
so it turns out that scientists actually
often and I'll show you this don't put
in enough information into the paper to
make the research resources the
antibodies and the software tools and
what have you easily identifiable and
there are lots and lots of different
ways in which we've actually chosen how
to talk about a particular thing we are
incredibly incredibly creative when we
talk about all kinds of things including
antibodies but that actually doesn't
help us find these things
if we all said exactly the same thing
right if we all set it in exactly the
same way it would actually be really
easy to find but we don't do that we we
are very creative people so we will
write these things in a very creative
way
in fact we are so creative sometimes
with our nomenclatures that no one can
find anything so let me show you a
really easy example so here's a
nomenclature for a mouse that this
particular author is using now this
particular author calls this mouse the
nod peak a skid il-2 receptor gamma
chain no mouse and they tell us that
they bought it from Jackson laboratories
so as a you know reasonably aware of the
web kind of a person I go and I type
that into the Jackson Laboratory website
and I get back not maybe with antibodies
it would be better so the same author
and many many many many of his friends
actually discusses that they you know
this author used fitc anti-human cd19
from BD and they tell us it's in
Franklin Nick like Lakes New Jersey um
and so cows a human being I go to the BT
catalog and I find no products that
actually match this search right so
that's a problem because these two
things that are the basic ingredients of
this particular study are not there now
this is not the only author that
actually does this and in fact when
Vasilevsky at home
in 2013 looked very carefully across all
of biomedicine all of the different
subfields of biomedicine a lot of the
different impact factors of journals and
and she went ahead and she looked at
this entire set of data that just was
just basically her going through and
trying to find these antibodies find
these cell lines constructs and
organisms and she said could I find this
thing
and in 50% of the cases she could not
find the antibody or the cell line or
other things so we are as a field really
bad at doing this but can we fix this of
course we can fix it right
and the question is how do you do that
well instead of putting you know
whatever Lakes right how about we just
put in an identifier and then that
identifier will actually tell us what is
that thing
so one identifier pictured here is AF
1494 which is catalog number of course
that's not globally unique but I'll show
you that in a second and then another
one is this RIT
and we will talk a lot more about this
so the history of these are our IDs what
are these things well in 2009 we thought
hey there's a problem we can't find
enough information in papers and then
moving on down the line we had many
starts and and some of them worked out
some of them really didn't work that we
we thought we learned some things back
in 2010 and 11 we actually reported our
findings about these catalog numbers to
the entire Editorial Board of the
journal for Neuroscience they use a lot
of antibodies and they said wow that's
terrible and a year later nothing had
changed so we said okay well that's it's
not enough just to say hey this is a bad
thing right we should do better no
actually what we need to do is we need
to create a system which allows the
journals to come in and basically make
this better so how do we do that right
so what we did is we actually followed
up we created a whole system in order to
make this really easy for the journals
we had their input we have their buy-in
we had them all in a workshop at NIH and
it was great because they got to say my
problem is that I have all of these
different things that I need to worry
about so how can you help me solve this
problem to make methods better to make
them more transfer
Aaron without the author having to go to
50 different websites right so then we
put together this portable which
aggregates all 50 things that they
needed to that they needed to get into
one place along a uniformed search and
we started in earnest in 2014 we
launched the Riv project and we were
able to essentially move forward from
there so from that point on we were
wrapping on we were adding journals and
I will show you some of that ok so just
at a very base level what are our IDs so
the our ID is sort of like a unique
barcode and that unique barcode is for
things like mice so here is an MMR SC
mouse strain datasheet and you can see
that there's a citation identifier with
the full already syntax right there also
for for things like antibodies so again
this is a product catalog from bio
legend and there is the R ID for this
particular for this particular antibody
so a scientist who wants to do an
experiment what um there's a little
pointer thing where is that okay so if
you look up here on the upper right hand
side you see the scientist who's who's
performing an experiment and that
scientist will actually go in they will
look for these particular kinds of
research resources so they'll they'll
buy their mounts they'll buy their
antibody they will do the experiments
that they are going to perform to ask
the scientific question about those you
know which involve these these research
resources and then when they go to
report the publishers including some
that you can see here on the Society for
Neuroscience under current society light
cell press and others will actually ask
these authors for those identifiers and
then when their paper comes out you can
start to do interesting things so
remember that that recipe well here is a
paper and this particular paper actually
links back to
antibody and that is now that is
additional information that somebody
reading this can click on to then go
back and find more information about
that particular product so others so
Elsevier has actually done even more
they've actually created an app that
displays the the antibodies that are
used in a particular paper and though
that actually contains more information
so we know what the vendor is we know
clonality we know some of the other
things about this antibody and that just
pops up on the side of the paper so we
have many ways of naming these things
right we have the name itself you know
whatever that name is for that reagent
or resource we have a catalog number of
stock number and then we have this our
ID why do we need this thing right why
do we need in our ID well we have stock
numbers well if the stock number is 0 25
right how do you know that's a volume
versus a mouse you may not the names of
these things are actually
extraordinarily good they're very
precise but it's actually very hard to
follow for many authors how you know how
to actually properly assign or
understand the nomenclature and the our
ID is a little bit maybe somewhere
between a stock number and a name it
definitely has a syntax stock number
here is locally unique so if you ask a
particular catalogue hey do what do you
have the 100l that catalogue will be
able to tell you hey I I do and here it
is if you don't know which catalogue to
go after then that 108 L or the 225 or
the CL 1515 is a little bit more
meaningless so there's something called
locally unique and then our ID is
actually based on a lot of these not
always but it's actually globally unique
so you can actually ask a very specific
question of Google and you will get back
answers about these
so stock number is essentially for
customers
the RIT is for authors and also for
search engines so this actually helps
both of those kinds of characters and
the names are really for curators or for
researchers that are very well-versed in
nomenclature and have been trained on
understanding nomenclature which is
unfortunately not as many people as we
need so the name actually will tell you
what is this thing what are the genetic
differences between this particular
animal and this is a mouse and another
Mouse right so this will actually tell
you things about the genetics of that
mouse whereas the stock number will tell
you where I where you can buy it and the
our ID is how do how do I cite this
thing so that it's recognizable by
machines and also all of your friends
and of course they all have to work
together so if we look at the actual
anatomy of an RIT we have this this RIT
portion which is I use this entity I use
this thing in my study it's not I'm
talking about it I'm using it then the
zerk here is the repository or the
authority so circ is where you go to buy
this other local identifier so there is
a ZL 15 15 and this happens to be a fish
but the entire syntax is is demonstrated
here so if we look at the entire syntax
we're actually looking at Milla port
which is the company or the provider we
have the local identifier here we
suggest that the author always uses the
lot some do some don't but then there's
the global identifier and this comes
from a repository and a registry for
this kind of reagents so in the case of
antibodies like is listed here
there's the antibody registry and that
is the antibody registry identifier so
what should authors do with these things
well and the author's workflow what the
journal does is they direct authors to
this particular website so this is a
sigh crunch portal and they are going to
search for their their particular
research resources so in this case 108 L
is is the thing that I'm searching for
and what you can see is that this is the
eyeless wild-type salamander larvae and
the stoma mexicana and here's a little
bit more information you can click on
that button and you can actually get
back to and a stoma stop Center and this
is how you cite that particular that
particular salamander so if you click on
that copy paste this into your paper
then the paper is published and now once
the paper is published what happens is
it actually becomes data so then
somebody else who's not you can go in
and they can search for in this case
this is a mouse they can search for the
six six four mouths excuse me and this
Mouse happens to have been already
published in 147 different papers sorry
so is this a hard thing to do it turns
out that when asked the authors at a
life were asked to fill out kind of a
brief survey just to figure out okay now
he life is making everybody do this and
you know is it really at the bad guy for
making them do this but it turned out
that all of our responses were really
positive from authors and they said
really nice things like you know adding
a Jennifer identifier has actually
turned out to be very easy so that was
from one paper with the authors of one
paper and another paper basically said
well you know besides helping other labs
to actually reproduce our own work we
don't always know what all of the
different reagents were so this is a
really good way of just making sure that
we keep track
exactly what's used in this paper so
that it's it's therefore for lab members
in the future so again these are these
are really nice things that basically
can you know can can help not just other
labs but also potentially our own labs
in the future so the other reason why
this is a really important thing to do
is if I am an author I am about to
publish my paper
maybe I checked with the IC Lac
authority before I bought my cell line
and maybe I didn't but before I publish
a new paper with a particular cell line
I may want to know whether the
authoritative source on contaminated
cell lines has said anything about the
cell line that I'm using and let me make
sure that this is clear there are cell
lines that you can buy today they're
actually contaminated there are over 700
of them 700 cell lines are not actually
what they say they are before they get
into your lab now we always know that
there are also antibodies that have
problems and other things but this is a
really clear case where at least before
you publish the paper that information
should be consulted and the nice thing
is when you go and find your re ID you
have that information right there so
here I have executed a search in the
resource identification portal for cell
lines and this is the one 5c for cell
line and I don't I didn't say anything
about this being contaminated right but
what comes up is hey this is the cell
line here is the repository and look at
that comment problematic cell line it's
contaminated this is shown to be Gila
derivative and there actually if you
click on this and you go out to cell
asaurus that aggregates a lot of this
information they actually work with this
IC Lac community to make sure that that
information is in
soon as it comes out from from ace I see
black the the information is right there
so when somebody is citing this
particular cell line they will know that
at some point in the in the past the I
see black community had found that that
particular cell line was contaminated so
again that could save your retraction
now why should journals care about these
are IDs so looking at it from the
perspective of a journal one of the
things that it does is it actually takes
all of these different critters so we
saw ambystoma I think we saw a couple of
examples of mice
we saw some examples of antibodies and
even cell lines but everything is all in
one including software tools here the
fish the rats
we even have pigs and pond scum but all
of these things are sitting inside of
one place one portal so the author's
that you're asking to do this only have
to go to one place and the format is
very consistent so always there are
notes there are comments there is a site
this button or you know again there's a
site this field in all of these things
the button is kind of covered over by
how many things we have but it's it's
there in all of the port in the portal
so that it's very consistent across
every kind of organism across every kind
of research resource we work with again
we work with all of the the model
organism communities the big ones and
we're more than happy to work with
others
but there's not just one database there
actually - there's a master copy so that
when a particular fish is no longer sold
it's fine right the antibody
manufacturers don't always sell the same
products but if you're going to buy that
product and then use it for scholarship
there's a different thing that you need
other than the catalog so the thing that
you need
is hey this thing was there I used it it
was used by these 12 other papers and
now it's gone so in this case this
particular fish is no longer indexed by
source database this is gone you cannot
buy this right now but that's okay
you may have it in your lab you may have
used it in your experiment you should be
able to cite it it shouldn't matter that
a particular vendor doesn't have that
thing anymore
right because we still have the data so
that's the comparison to the master copy
and that information continues to be
there it continues to be resolvable it's
kind of like the library card catalog
you know you don't have the book but at
least you know it was there okay so
again are these are persists
they are persistent so this is what a
persistent unique identifier does so it
lives there it's the card catalog like
thing which tells you there was a fish
this is what it was called this is what
we know about it hearing the papers that
were published with it but maybe you
can't get that anymore okay
so the other thing that it does when we
went back a couple of years later and we
really look deeply at the first 100
papers that were published with our IDs
and asked the question that Vasil Levski
adult asked two years before and we said
did this make a difference in that
journal in those papers did it make a
difference to ask for our IDs and in
fact this this plot right here shows you
that in fact it does make a difference
it makes a huge difference right so
antibodies were identifiable these are
now looking at the same journals just
the issue before our IDs came out and
then the same journal with the issue
just after people were we're asking for
our IDs and what you can actually see is
that the identifiability so can I find
this thing goes way up that goes way up
so what we are really doing and this
is a great paper with these nice links
to these particular mice what we're
really doing is we're getting rid of the
citation format for this mouse which
looks like this you know ERC mouse from
jackson laboratories in Barbour blah
blah blah blah blah right and we're
actually we're shortening it so this
this is a better because it's shorter
format and it also will give you the
actual mess so the added benefit oh you
can actually find the mouse which is
very nice okay now what if you made a
mouse or you made an antibody well it
turns out that if you make a mouse or if
you make an antibody and someone did
make this antibody um what you can do if
people cited very specifically then you
can actually pull back potentially all
the papers if we can you know get this
instituted and enough of the literature
we can pull back the bulk of the papers
or all of the papers that are actually
using that antibody by talking about it
very specifically sorry and there is no
need because this is a Google Scholar
I'm not even logged in page I can just
look at this put this ID in and get back
all of the data no need for fancy tools
no need for natural language processing
but when people use identifier it
actually does more things right it's not
just I can put it into Google Scholar
again as a search string to make it
unique but it actually what it does is
it starts to become an ecosystem of
identifiers and that ecosystem of
identifiers is you know there are a lot
of them the papers each paper has an
identifier actually has several right so
potentially it's got at least a DOI and
a PubMed ID if you're going to be
indexed by PubMed probably has a PubMed
central ID if you're going to put it
into PubMed Central and these
identifiers make the paper unique so if
there's a version on my desktop there's
a version on an HTML web page and
there's a version and that's a PDF and
there's a version over in PubMed Central
these identifiers actually tell me hey
that's the same paper it's kind of
important if you look at something like
an author it turns out I actually
published a paper with somebody whose
name was Y dot Li Li and all of the
websites for some reason could never
ever get to the right person there's a
lot of Lee's not as many van drops keys
but there are some so a lot of our names
are not unique right so we have now
orchids and orchids are very very useful
because they differentiate that why
don't we
or that a Gupta or you know the Marton
or the John Smith or whatever else right
so we want to be able to differentiate
the person that we're actually talking
about that's the author it's not you
know some generic John Smith's right
it's this one it's this one specifically
and so again we have four authors we
have orchids four papers we have duis
funding so grants absolutely have
numbers data sets and code often have do
is book said is BMS but research
resources actually have our IDs and they
work very similarly to these papers they
work very similarly to the author IDs so
the orchids so the goal of the findable
accessible interoperable data right and
findable accessible interoperable
research resources is to link different
kinds of artifacts together including
people what we want to do is we want to
have all of the evidence where a claim
is based on a whole set of procedures to
allow us right to now link back to all
of these sections which we do know and
we know very very well okay
and we want to do that by using unique
identifiers that way we can actually
start to create interesting graphs who
was that person so not only for
disambiguating what was the funding
papers were produced and which resources
were used all of these things need to
actually be utilized in order to trace
the utilization and trace the impact of
what we're doing so again if I make a
mouse and nobody tells anyone else which
mounts they're using no one can find it
anywhere
I can't report back to my grant to my to
my funding officer hey somebody used
this mouse but I have no idea who maybe
they'll write me a nice letter but
that's not repeatable that's not
traceable so we want to use these
identifiers so that our impact is
actually traceable and let me just show
you something kind of fun so when we
have this kind of structured data or no
not even completely structured data but
we have these articles like this with
these identifiers this is a mouse what
we can do is actually we can read those
by using robots and this is my little
picture of a very cool reading robot and
so if you look at this if you click on
it you can actually get to a page that
looks kind of similar to this but what I
can do with my little 15 lines of Python
robot is actually I can put the same
information back into the paper so now I
can I'm reading along and this is a
particular not mouse and this is what
the database says about that Mouse and
if I click on that I actually get back
to the stock center itself so I can
actually know much more about this
particular reagent then somebody who is
just reading the paper and so this robot
is actually pretty well described here
in in a blog from from jon udell
and there are a bunch of examples this
is one so PubMed Central if you just
type in to PubMed Central you know for
ten 7038 you'll get back to the to a
paper that you know has an example of
what one of these things looks like so
you can certainly do that and I
urge you to explore these kind of robots
and these kind of overlays into the
literature so what we do with a lot of
this robot reading is actually we take
the papers we process them by having the
the robot actually help our curators to
to read the paper brings back the
information and now we've made an
assertion or we've exposed an assertion
about a paper which has an identifier
and a tool that has an identifier so in
this case this is the abyss tool and
this this tool now is associated with a
particular paper and this paper is again
from Giga science so Giga science has
published a paper this is the the title
of the paper it's by phu waifu and then
this paper is now associated with the
record for that particular that
particular software tool so this
information then flows and it flows very
quickly to the tools and so now if I'm
told if I'm the tool maker for this
particular tool what I can do is I can
download all of my citations so this is
a Citation Index that comes straight out
from just the person essentially citing
this particular tool using the ID and
again that can happen normally by
somebody reading and saying oh wait you
know that is the abyss but because this
can be read by robots because this can
be read very very quickly and
automatically then what ends up being
able to happen is that that information
can be automatically pushed so if we
look at how many are these there are
there are over 4,000 papers now we're
you know very soon to hit 4500 which is
not a huge amount yet the number of
journals that we have is currently at
349 different journals and the types of
tools so if you look at this this the
donut ring here most of the things that
are being cited are actually antibodies
and that's just by number tool it just
refers to software tools or databases
and cell lines which came on a little
bit later to the project are here in
green and then of course lots of mice
some flies and then a smattering of
other other critters but if you look at
the number of papers the number of times
that one of these things is used the
most useful tool apparently according to
our you know subset of 4,300 papers is
the image J tool the next one is
graphpad prism MATLAB and there's our
and SPSS and and down here you actually
see that mouse which is the c57 black 6
mouse actually it turns out to be very
very popular everybody likes that Mouse
if you look at the antibodies actually
this is the most popular one that's one
from Milla poor and there's a couple
from thermo down here most of these
antibodies that are used in many many
many papers they're actually secondary
antibodies but you know this this list
continues for about 50,000 rows so it's
a it's actually quite quite long but so
if we make it one of these tools now we
can look at one of those tool pages so
this is image J so if I had created
image J I could do various things I
could actually log in to edit this
particular page so if I search in the
RIT portal ice type an image J I hit
enter and I get into image J here
there's a lovely description and I say
oh no no that description is wrong all
wrong Oh what I can do is I can change
it right there's also a bunch of
information in these tabs so there's
kind of the basic information these are
keywords your grants and all of that
there's a bunch of relationships with
other tools so if you were part of a
university there would be a relationship
with the university the paper about the
tool is here so you know there's a
specific idea I made this tool and here
I write a paper about it great
that doesn't always happen at the same
time in fact often there's a pretty big
disconnect so for this particular tool
image J actually we had we had some
interesting analysis of this because it
took many many years like over a decade
for somebody to write a paper about this
really useful tool and by that time it
had already appeared in hundreds of
papers but then there's this section
here which is the referenced by so if
you click on that you'll see how many
people are talking about your tool if
you have your tool you can see that
particular component so again you can
also claim ownership of this tool so I
made this tool and you know there can be
multiple owners just like for every
paper there can be multiple authors and
then you can actually subscribe
subscribe to new mentions so if there is
a new paper that comes out and it says
hey I used mhj then next time you log in
you would say hey looks like this this
paper actually talked about your tool
and that's kind of cool the other thing
you can do is you can go into your
profile if you've actually created one
and you can you know just look at the
name so this is my name and here's my
working and that working so there's a
button here that says associate your
orchid and if you have an orchid great
good job I congratulate you and you know
great if you don't have an orchid I
really recommend getting one it takes
maybe two minutes but what it does is it
then it starts to aggregate your funding
information your the fact that you're at
a particular university and what you've
published all gets fed into your orchid
profile and this orchid profile can be
used by institutional review boards
maybe it will maybe it won't but it's
it's one of the options that tenure and
review committees can can actually get
information from your orchid profile so
work is great for that and one of the
things that we're really working on
right now is
to connect up again the fact that I
might own a tool I may have created a
tool so let's let's pretend I didn't do
it but let's pretend that I made image J
and what I would be able to do is I
would be able to claim and actually move
to orchid the information that I made a
particular tool so in this case this is
my orchid and here's my orchid page and
so my orchid page there's a native and
rescue and rescue that's nice at all
kind of more or less fits in a e versus
Anita well could that be me yes it that
could because there's my IB so there is
the ID and then what you see here is
that there's the antibody registry
database now this is not a paper in fact
we have not yet written a paper about
the antibody registry database but we
have created the antibody registry
database and it is in use trust me just
see a couple of slides ago so you know
this database is being used it's but it
doesn't yet have a paper associated with
it which is actually fairly common
apparently in the database world so what
I have for it though is an our ID and
here it is and so now this sits inside
of my orchid profile now if my tenure
committee wants to use this information
they can and in fact we're working on an
integration with orchid so that we can
do this and ask authors of tools whether
they want that information to be pushed
to or kit so if you've created a tool a
software tool at this point is how we
what we've enabled you can do that today
and within some months we should be able
to enable and allow for both antibody
creators and then other research
resource creators to kind of do the same
thing so we'll need to get this all
worked out but this is where we want to
get to we want to say there are parts of
intellectual work that are not papers
and those should be accounted for in
some way
who chooses how to do that you know how
did how to evaluate a particular
scientist and their their intellectual
output based on that particular type of
work is up to them but for us we want to
push this information out there we want
to give them the ability to to judge
people not just on the papers they've
written not just on the you know
abstracts that they've presented and put
in for conferences but you know give
given the fact that hey maybe somebody
made an antibody that then allowed
cancer to be cured well great you know I
think that person deserves some credit
for that maybe not a curing of cancer
but some credit for that should be
should be given so the other things that
we're working on
in terms of putting this data out there
about these papers so for example this
again is is a project from the crossref
folks and the crossref folks now have
data about events that happen to a
particular paper and those events can be
many many things they can be somebody
tweeted about the paper somebody you
know wrote a blog about this paper
somebody downloaded this paper and all
of that and so one of the events is well
we had a reading of this paper by this
automated tool when a curator opened the
paper then that was associated with a
whole bunch of things including oh look
there is there is a mouse right so this
mouse is part of now this the record for
this particular paper in the event
database so we work currently with
hypothesis which has a w3c compliant
annotation standard that allows all of
this to to kind of all of this kind of
data to flow back into crossref so now
CrossRef if you guys are not familiar
with CrossRef chris Roth is a is the
kind of provider for most of the duis so
you click on the DOI that little link
that takes you to the paper that's
provided a lot of times by by CrossRef
okay so if we're going to look at sort
of how many how many journals and how
many papers over what period of time
that we're actually seeing what we see
is that since we started the project in
2014 where we started with 25 journals
we currently have over 300 we started
with or actually ended late 2014 with
115 papers
the rate of increase is roughly doubling
so if that continues which it appears to
be so for our continuing it will take us
between five and ten years to kind of be
a much more pervasive set of identifiers
in the literature and we will buy I
think seven years at this rate be in all
of the 23,000 journals that are in
PubMed so we look forward to that these
are currently the top publishers so if
you look at Wiley it's on top and sell
press is the third one I'm not sure what
happens okay I think there we go okay so
I just wanted to kind of wrap up and say
there are a lot of papers being
published every single every single year
in PubMed and the reason that we've
really started to invest a lot of our
energy into building automated systems
building some of these robots is because
really when you want to improve tracking
when we want to improve how we move data
about papers and how we allow different
kinds of data to go from one place to
another about individual papers so for
example who cited whom is something that
we kind of understand but
who cited which Mouse is not yet as
well-developed so we want to be able to
do is we want to inject machines as much
as possible into this equation so that
the tracking and the impact of resources
becomes a more simple and
straightforward thing to be able to do
we want to help authors actually do this
better we want to provide more of this
credit to tool makers and we want to
improve the way that they they do this
reduce the better barrier to entry we
want to be able to also inject some of
that information into papers where it's
you know where there's clearly something
where the reader might want to know hey
you know when they they publish this
paper this particular cell line may have
been okay but at the moment we
understand that there is there was a
contamination event that was reported so
we're not really sure so you know take
this with a grain of salt which everyone
should anyway but having that
information right there in front of the
reader tends to make this this process
much easier so we want to provide this
information to authors we want to
provide it to to readers as well okay so
is there anything that you can do turns
out you can actually add your tool if
you have created a tool you can use the
our ID in your methods section please do
if your journal editor asks you for
doing it please do it if your journal
editor does not ask you it turns out
most of the time you can just get them
in there anyway so those things just
help us track and it's it's a fairly
straightforward system when you review a
paper
whenever I review a paper I look at the
methods and I look at the methods
because I have to look at for the our
IDs and
turns out when I talked to my editor
colleagues when they review for our IDs
they look at the methods more frequently
and they have actually told me that they
caught really big problems because they
were looking more carefully at the
methods so this is just one way again
it's a shortcut to look to look at the
methods and to really review the methods
instead of just reviewing you know what
the author actually said and of course
if you have a journal please talk to me
my email is at the bottom and a band
drops key at UCSD please talk to me
about it and I would love to you know
I'd love to be able to to come together
and say hey we can do something for your
journal okay so thank you and I really
appreciate your attention I believe that
excuse me I believe that um we're gonna
now cut this off because I believe that
I have run out of time okay thank you
thank you so much dr. bender Oskie for
that informative presentation in your
important research and thank you to the
audience for participation in questions
dr. band röszke will be emailing answers
to those participants who sent in
questions I'd also like to take the
opportunity to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcasts
possible before we go I want everyone to
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
December 2017 you'll receive an email
from laborat letting you know when the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye